janneh a pleuré lorsqu'il a vu pour la
toute première fois ce ton idole de
jeunesse ainsi bilal c'est comme se
rencontrer son idole de jeunesse puis
voir en personne c'est quelque chose
moi je trouve ça super mouvement la
fumée des gratte-ciel le gris de la
ville on voit tout ça dans le monde
dungy bilal il a un style unique
émouvant
ses personnages ont des teintes de gris
et de bleu c'est un choix il n'est pas
très électrique il ya toujours un peu de
gris vous parlez de gris tout à l'heure
je n'ai jamais du grill à elle parce
qu'il ya peu beaudry mais je mets
souvent du gris dans le bleu pour lui
donner un côté un peu froid mais parce
que ça ça lui donne je pense un côté
plus sensuelle qu'un bleu purement
électrique dès ses débuts
bilal a brassé le monde de la bd des
années 1970 avec son coup de crayon il a
toujours mis en scène des femmes fortes
au départ il y avait peut-être une
réaction par rapport au monde un peu
macho de l'ue monde de la bande dessinée
les les filles c'était des bimbos 20
mois je trouvais ça un peu un peu
ringard un taux ridicule visionnaire
bilal a anticipé les échecs des hommes
du 20e siècle
parmi ses faits d'armes il y a le
classique partie de chasse illustrant la
fin du communisme en europe de l'est
six ans avant la chute du mur de berlin
dans le sommeil du monstre paru trois
ans avant le 11 septembre 2001
il traitait du retour en force du
terrorisme et de l'obscurantisme
religieux
effectivement on peut dire que le
visionnaire oui et non mais simplement
je me pose des questions sur notre futur
ce que peu de ce que les journalistes ne
peuvent pas se faire réellement
est-ce que peu d'auteurs peut-être dans
la culture française font quoi de plus
naturel donc pour bilal de parler de
l'année 2041 avec sa série bones année
où le monde perd toutes les données
d'internet et donc sa mémoire n'est ton
père déjà en train de devenir un peu
paresseux des cas mémoire est-ce qu'on
confie patrouille au numérique
j'ai une sorte de paresse on confie tout
numérique officier
invité d'honneur du salon du livre de
montréal enki bilal planchent sur la
suite de bogues
janet lui repart encore ému d'avoir
rencontré son idole vous allez le garder
précieusement ce livre là j'imagine ans
oui peut-être encadré ici louis philippe
ouimet radio canada montréal